Cernik without him joining us here it's
always great CBS analyst who will be
working this week with the Pebble Beach
pro-am on CBS and Jim Nantz will join us
a little bit later on his cohort there
in the booth how would you describe that
last lesson you just gave us on the
practice room reel reel I you know I
honestly I've done this in the past in
different places there were people come
on to play with union there are
petrified and I say we'll just copy me
and that or I've a guy shank the go
shank yeah so I stood out with a 6-iron
and I said just watch I put two balls up
I said right I'll hit that one
imagine I'm on a TV screen I said soak
it up I won't say a word I'll step out
you'd step into my ghost as they call it
make a swing and Bosh right down the
middle cured him in one the one-shot
wonder are you a good teacher I believe
I am yeah I think as I I got a very
different I bit we'll just took it to
Tony Romo last night you know we see
things a little bit differently
obviously so and I learned to condense
it down to I think I'm a good teacher
because I see a lot of things and I
bring it right down and I know if you
just do this one or two moves that
should correct an awful lot of things
rather than giving you 19 different
things to think of but Jordan speith
said he couldn't teach he wouldn't be a
good - you know it's funny funny I stood
behind I was stood behind Pete Sampras
I'm the tennis lesson and there's Pete
right how cool is out right in front of
me
given this so and going you know this is
how I did it for to win Wimbledon buff
and I said so how do you do it he goes
honest honest nobody don't know know any
such as coaches how do I hold it I don't
know where it's a good start so some
guys can demonstrate it fantastically
right in front of you and others can
verbalize yeah did you want to be a
tennis player growing up I did funny
enough and you know was one of the
sports I went down I taught I was a
sports man looking for a sport and I and
I went down and said tennis they met for
six three you're too tall because
everything was broad labor size yeah
that 10 and hey now look they're 9 foot
now you know so it's no so that was yes
tried it I was I was waiting for the
coach
and that sort of thing I tried swimming
cycling I did all the schools but I was
good at all of that cricket rugby soccer
I didn't goal in soccer so I used to
dive the wrong way
do you have a favorite soccer team no I
don't now I left England when they were
going through the hooliganism stage in
the 80s and I lost but I watch it now
it's cool cuz he's right there on you on
your big screen and when you having
breakfast at home school a Tony Romo's
serious about playing on tour playing on
tour we're trying to qualify or get
sponsors exemptions I yeah I think you
could good enough for what Steph Curry
did it was fantastic I mean it-it's
really difficult to come out of your
sport that you're so good at and go and
do something in and stand up and play
golf because you is we know what golf's
like it's not like hey I can take a
timeout on the 16th because I'm nine
over and I still gotta finish haven't
like oh I'm having a good day and I can
still finish double-double you have to
finish around the golf playing there our
game and so here if he's good enough and
thinks he can go out and I think right
now it's all cool it's all cool for our
sport to see well they're great athletes
you think Steph Curry could play on tour
I thought away for one week that was
pretty darn good he had a great touch
didn't I think Weaver yeah you actually
could have give him a month and a month
or four tournaments really competitive
and see what he could do I think that's
fair to come out and do what he did in
just one go I thought was very very good
for in person who's the most famous
person you play golf with who I played a
little boy America will be clinically
knees with well yes caddy for Clinton
how cool is that yesterday I mean that's
you come you've got a true genuine
legend he's a bit like he's bit like
Elton into their mega stars and so I can
talk smack we'd planned yesterday I
thought that's pretty darn cool wait
what about Europe who'd you with Prince
Andrew you know we used to play a chess
sneak down and plague I used to sneak
and player wisly forest Prince ended
with my son
lad Matthew was a little lemon Prince
Andrew taught Matthew Fowler how to tie
his shoelaces that's how my claim to
fame wait you couldn't teach him how to
tie I couldn't father father comes he
just son anything you know dad you don't
know you don't know how to lace is dead
you know call him Prince or do you call
me Andy and call him Sir
yes oh you do yes yeah you you you greet
the royal family we've obviously heard
majesty if you bump into the Queen in
Windsor and and everybody else is your
highness and then says and that's but if
you're playing gone yeah he had a thing
called the royal isla musa ler royal oh
this is great so in a nosal it is and
those are is you get you play something
you can have a shot and you can use it
wherever you want
right but the Royal Isla is you can
recall us us if you just hold a part
across the green for your birdie and
you're all excited I can go Royal loser
play it again
so you know gotta play again push unit
yeah and so we were playing at Turnberry
and so I'm I have the Royal Euler and
and and and hold a 30-foot park I think
across the 14th green I'm standing with
my arms in the air and my manager oh my
god no you can't even I can't do now so
I'm screaming they could hey I here's
another secret but I said do they have
an ensuite in the Tower of London I
don't know if this is a real secret but
apparently they thought if they captured
Hitler they were gonna bring him back to
the Tower of London and they is it there
is a cell in the Tower of London which
is on sweep for Hitler I believe that's
one of my who knows if that's a true
story but it's a good night it's got
your you idiocy yes it did
now okay does your family call you sir
Nick Faldo is your wife call you sir
Nick no it doesn't have a wife so that
that doesn't happen
now of course it goes it does nobody has
to say blood Tony
Tony Romo call you sir before he better
did ya Jim Nantz does he always
technically that is my official title
and we're asked by our government to
uphold the traditions of our country
it's cooler me Utley I think you know it
was Sir starting in in 1357 that's not
two minutes two three four you humps
guns okay - mister - two - 13 being the
one get it so it started all those moons
ago so I think that's I'm I'm honored
that I'm we were asked to uphold our
traditions so yeah and it's alright you
can call me snake snake you what you can
call me snake little little combination
of the two layer again I like that we're
going to Jim Nancy's house for brunch
today while you soup yeah any advice any
advice don't whatever you do when he
goes to the fridge door he'll open the
door the light will come on and he does
45 minutes it's like hello friends
good morning good morning eggs you know
geez Jim I'm over here and he makes an
anthem --let he has announced omelets
special recipes Rick I think it's
probably on the wall on the menu of the
day now do we have to wear like sweaters
and plaid and trouble you know what
sweater you now have to wear you have to
go with your whale of a time sweater you
know what I mean I've got to get a
cardigan or something their car and
we're how about this idea you press the
doorbell uh-huh it says hello friends
probably yeah and then we have the
Masters music it's the Masters like as
soon as you go in is that the only song
that play we just have the Masters theme
Spotify or Pandora just the OGG woods in
azaleas over there yeah white dog woods
from the 11th hole yeah magnolias yeah
then we have the putting green of number
seven number seven nothin here oh seven
here is a copy of the seventh grade Oh
cuz I thought it was 12 million uh
Courtney got entwined on the seventh we
were there for the wedding was fantastic
but so he's got a little replica bit
like this size a little bigger than this
double this size with of course the four
championship hole locations on that
Johnson and again you go back and you
play this it's a really
all golf boys you know you chip it from
40 it's about 45 yards long and you chip
and the thing flies like a wedge shot 40
I need and you make holy ones he's got a
hole in one board you to go make a hole
in one and you'll get your name on the
board yeah you'll be you'll be there
he's a sir Nick Faldo snick joining us
here the Dan Patrick show the Sun rises
coming here looks pretty good yeah yeah
yeah it's gonna be another let's stay in
do you are now Bay you ever been
mistaken for somebody fritzy said you
look like a younger Harrison Ford yeah
yeah nothing but the real yes many a
times first big time was in Japan when
we actually would take the plane at all
because the traffic's the bad in Japan
we would take the tube you know to the
golf course of moons ago that some team
event we were playing and they would the
school kids - oh cod first started that
one and then my best one I'm sitting on
a plane in Asia on the way and the and
the steward comes over and he said do
you ever get mistaken for Nick Faldo no
honest do you ever get mistaken for Nick
Felder the golfer and I so I said only
on my days off he's seen he goes to hell
and he comes back up be you're much more
famous than him yeah tell us how this
plays out this weekend here this torrent
yep well we hope we hope Jordans back in
the running we heard we got the best
probe field for moons we hope Jordans in
the running of course we hope Rory's in
the running we hope Adam Scott's in the
running Jay Jay days here my good
Dustin Johnson where that is pretty darn
good at the top end so if we could get
three of the top six Sunday afternoon
it'll be big what do you expect an April
from Tiger I I want to see you know he
what he did it Torrey Pines a couple of
weeks back now he's playing next week at
Riviera so I want to see the
improvements he has spotted himself
cause he know he's he's think as we call
in the timing was out you know when
that's when I was describing the body
goes fast in the arms earlier and you've
got to know what you did
especially when you want to work the
golf ball so he was well and truly out
of sync so if he can disappear for two
weeks and work on it and come back and
bring and put his finger on it at
Riviera
I will go great very impressive let's
keep moving off he comes back to Riviera
and it's still going left and right then
we will see but I want I want to give
him time and he's gonna play Honda as
well so that's actually just straight
after so actually we're gonna get him
two weeks in a row so yeah let's let the
guy go and play for two weeks back to
back that'll be another test physically
I think the back is amazing yeah I mean
he's swingin hundred twenty-five miles
an hour in the noon with nuts and bolts
in his back that is incredibly
impressive so let's see the longevity
you know the fatigue factor as you call
it over here how long it will last how
well he will go for a couple of weeks
and but short game parting parting
stroke was still as pure as ever so he's
got to get all of that how good can he
get that can canny then put it into as I
call it into the the scare zone when you
were in contention Saturday afternoon
and then Sunday and then then we'll find
out how good it is again snick Faldo
joining us here and you can have see
more here more of Nick coming up this
weekend on CBS as they bring you the
AT&T Pebble Beach pro-am Nick thank you
again for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]